today I teach at times about a place
called Africa
[Applause]
you say our Mama's come from Queens over
there
that means that we
royalty
[Music]
need you to love me
afternoon
I need my wife
even if we have to part you and me us
have one heart
[Music]
you I'll write you every day
nothing but that can keep me from it
oh miss Felix you must ain't got no
Kinfolk around these parts all I had was
my sister
she was the only one ever loved me
[Music]
[Applause]
it's time for you to see the world
there's gonna be some changes made put
it on this ain't me hush we need to look
like we belong let's see the smile and
come
oh
sweet and loving God
now it's okay
[Applause]
[Music]
dear Celie we have more than just kings
and queens
we are at the center of the universe